du conseil régional à l'assemblée
nationale c'est le chemin qui espère
parcourir sandrine grandes jambes
la première adjointe de la ville de
trappes est candidate au poste de député
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
une campagne tournée principalement sur
la prise de conscience de la crise
environnementale et sociale des messages
forts à porter des rabais à la fois sur
le plan des politiques qui sont menées
qui ne conviennent pas aux populations
de la circonscription et puis il ya des
messages d alerte au niveau du
gouvernement et nous on veut porter une
voix à la fois fort sur l'écologie sur
la solidarité et des pratiques à mettre
en avant comme celle de l'entreprise
d'insertion envie à trappes qui recycle
les appareils électroménagers à la
candidate à visiter la structure avec
son suppléant nicolas phare et le député
européen mounir satouri d'europe
écologie les verts alliés de génération
pour le scrutin le parti souhaite
rassembler tous les écologistes pour
pouvoir aller plus fort porté un message
écologiste à l'assemblée nationale
permettent à sandrine il eut locales
engagées résolument écolo d'aller siéger
à l'assemblée nationale sarah mènera du
débat ça renforcera nos interventions
pas d'union plus large de la gauche en
revanche avec une autre candidature
celle des insoumis et communistes porté
par valérie froberger un rassemblement
et espérer en cas de second tour
les amis communistes et de la france a
soumises ont voulu se compter à part sur
cette élection là c'est leur droit
je pense que c'est dommage mais je reste
optimiste sur le fait que nous avons
vocation à nous rassembler de toute
façon si elle est élue députée sandrine
grand gant devra renoncer à l'un de ses
mandats locaux pour se conformer à la
loi
elle a indiqué qu'elle renoncerait à son
siège de conseillère régionale pour
garder son ancrage à trappes